there have been Air Raids and gunfire in
Sudan's capital a day before Humanity a
humanitarian truce is due to come into
effect between the Army and the
paramilitary rapid support forces the
two sides have been locked in a power
struggle since mid-april more than one
million people have been displaced by
the fighting at at least 850 killed the
seven-day ceasefire was broken by the
U.S and Saudi Arabia but both sides have
failed to honor previous agreements Al
jazeera's Heber Morgan has more on the
deal from on demand on the outskirts of
Khartoum
the ceasefire that was signed between
the Sudanese Army and the rapid support
forces does not come into effect until
around 9 45 PM local on Monday which is
around 1945 GMT now people here say that
they're going to wait and see how it
unfolds on the ground they've seen how
previous ceasefires have played out
between the two sides with the ongoing
sounds of artillery fire and airstrikes
being launched against the rsf by the
Sudanese Army despite the fact that both
sides have agreed to ceasefire this time
it's a bit different it's the first time
that the two sides actually signed on
paper on a ceasefire that is supposed to
last for seven days and there will be a
monitoring mechanism so there will be
three members from the rapid support
forces three members from the Sudanese
Army and six other members from the
United States and the Kingdom of Saudi
Arabia to monitor any violations in the
agreement the agreement also specifies
that there will be no use of heavy
artillery in residential areas and that
there should be no firing at each other
by both sides for humanitarian Aid to
come in and and that there should be no
airstrikes launched by the Sudanese Army
so this is the specifics or parts of the
specifics of the deal that was signed on
late Saturday between the rapid support
forces and the Sudanese Army in Jeddah
now people again here say that they
don't believe that it will actually hold
they want to see what happens on Tuesday
morning what happens on Wednesday and
when they actually see humanitarian AIDS
starting to come in when they feel that
they can actually leave their homes
because it's the situation is safer and
calmer and try to make it to safer zones
where there's no active fighting that's
when they'll know that the ceasefire is
holding it's also supposed to open
humanitarian corridors for those who are
in need of Aid here in the capital
Khartoum and in other parts of the
country especially the western region of
Darfur so people say that as much as
they want a ceasefire so that they can
be able to try to get basic Commodities
from the markets or for a to come in or
for them to be able to leave their homes
they're going to wait and see how the
first days of the ceasefire plays out
before they actually believe that
there's a ceasefire being implemented on
the ground